opposers this can't wait Rex Tillerson
has been fired he is no longer the
Secretary of State and this is what we
came to expect when you elect the
apprentice president you're gonna get
somebody who's gonna walk into a
boardroom make eye contact and say get
me the phone I need to tweet us somebody
on the other side of the world because
they're gonna be fired and then turn off
my phone cuz I don't want them texting
back because that could get awkward
in fact lock the doors cuz if Rex comes
back from Africa the point is he gets
done or he tweets things out that
gets done Rex bye-bye
[Music]
the fight continues good you hid down
here with a real truth lies you want to
help me defeat the globalists and stay
on the inside click and subscribe and
help me defeat them because following me
on my youtube channel makes you a leader
it tracks trust me